you're watching film cranium show you
here with wisely and why did you have
your own YouTube falling what's your
channel that
okay and what do you do on your channel
will videos
and so what wants you out to VidCon this
year what's your reason for coming up
well
at first I wasn't going to go and then a
lot of my friends cuz i know a lot of
people that work on youtube videos and
stuff
they said that I should go so decided to
go in character because a long time ago
I went in to a gathering before the
first Youtube gatherings
four years ago
same character so I hadn't been that
characters instance I wanted to try to
bring that character
so i can make more man
and so far from all the panels that
we've seen what have you gained
I really haven't been listening anyway I
have just been trying to message people
alright then have you have you had any
fun doing that what kind of prank it was
a lot I just interviewed some people and
they didn't know it was people i don't
know but i wasn't doing a mean-spirited
but one thing can happen but it wasn't
my fault well there was a lady she won a
streamy award and I was just being very
nice to I wasn't rude or anything but my
as when I walked away like my friend
said that he was like I was in a group
home and that he was watching me at this
group home and then she wanted to know
the name of it she sure did all this
information and then and then like she
walked away and I wanted to explain
sorry if you see this sorry
and you were also in one of my favorite
films ug with Jake varsha this director
he also had him on our show can you tell
us what it was like
Jake is an a-hole raise your hand
these are easygoing guy
thank you very much
you